una coalición tripartita podría gobernar
por primera vez en alemania durante una
semana los socialdemócratas liberales y
verdes han estado en conversaciones y
parece que sus acercamientos han
prosperado los tres partidos anunciaron
iniciar conversaciones formales para
formar un ejecutivo
las conversaciones exploratorias se
están llevando a cabo en un ambiente muy
muy bueno y constructivo y por eso estoy
seguro de que la intención de las tres
partes que están dialogando se puede
hacer realidad es decir que tendremos un
nuevo gobierno antes de navidad' vio los
posibles socios aseguran que se trata de
una oportunidad para modernizar alemania
y también para crear políticas concretas
contra el cambio climático estamos
convencidos después de estas
conversaciones de que durante mucho
tiempo no ha habido una oportunidad
comparable para modernizar la sociedad
la economía y el estado
para que la coalición se haga realidad
se necesita aún la aprobación del
liderazgo de los liberales así como la
de un congreso en el seno del partido
verde pero ya sus líderes se muestran
determinados a participar de este
ejecutivo
ahora vamos a proponer a todos nuestros
partidarios entrar juntos a estas
negociaciones de coalición
minds han de tener éxito sol se
convertiría en el nuevo canciller del
país finalizaría así un mandato de 16
años de los cristianos demócratas
comandados por la actual canciller
angela merkel el partido de merkel
obtuvo en las recientes elecciones
generales sus peores resultados en
décadas y cada vez es más posible que en
los próximos años deba sortear la crisis
que atraviesa desde la oposición